The wild and wacky halls of Greendale
Community College have hosted a ton of
big stars — and these are the ones who’ve
also gotten schwifty on "Rick and Morty."
Joel McHale played Jeff Winger, the de facto
leader of the main "Community" crew. A once
successful lawyer, his prestigious degree from
Columbia University is revealed to be a sham,
forcing him out of his career. In a bid
to return to his high-profile lifestyle,
Winger enrolls at Greendale Community
College to receive a legitimate degree,
where he becomes the leader of a colorful band
of misfits. After "Community" wrapped up in 2015,
McHale went on to star in "The X-Files" and
even played former "Community" co-star Chevy
Chase in the 2018 comedy "A Futile and Stupid
Gesture." However, he eventually reunited with
his "Community" boss Dan Harmon for the "Rick and
Morty" Season 3 episode "Rickmancing the Stone."
In this episode, Rick transports
his grandchildren, Morty and Summer,
to a "Mad Max"-style universe filled
with chaos and vehicular warfare.
McHale voiced the role of Hemorrhage,
the leader of a group that terrorizes
the wastelands. Summer falls for Hemorrhage,
but their love story doesn't last long. Rick
eventually helps the tribe become more civilized,
leading the macho Hemorrhage to adopt a simpler
and more docile way of life. Notably, Summer
isn't the only "Rick and Morty'' character to
enjoy a brief romance with a character
voiced by a former "Community" star.
In the "Rick and Morty" Season 5 episode "A
Rickconvenient Mort," Alison Brie voiced a
fictional, eco-conscious superhero named
Planetina. While on an adventure with his
grandfather, Morty encounters Planetina and
immediately falls for her. Surprisingly,
the shy superhero also takes a liking to the
high schooler, and the two begin to date,
much to the dismay of Morty's mother. After
hatching a plan to save Planetina from being
sold to a rich sheik, the two spend their days
together saving the planet. Unfortunately,
Morty learns that Planetina places more
value in protecting the planet than she
does in saving human lives, something that
forces the young man to break up with her.
Brie rose to prominence after appearing
as the do-good, straight-A student Annie
Edison in "Community." The youngest member
of the group, she often struggled to have her
voice heard and was taken advantage of for her
proficiency in school. Throughout "Community,"
she shares a will-they-won't-they relationship
with Jeff Winger, which is ironic considering the
two actors also both served as love interests
for different characters in "Rick and Morty."
The animated series doesn't seem too shy
about bringing back guest characters,
and Planetina's story also wasn't
quite wrapped up entirely yet,
so there's always the possibility that Brie's
character and Morty could reunite once again.
"And now the elemental punch
that's too hot to handle. Wa-kah!"
Gillian Jacobs made quite the splash when
she joined "Community" as Britta Perry,
an activist struggling to find meaning in her
life through community college. Britta appeared
as a series regular in "Community" throughout
its six-season run. After the star wrapped up
her time as Britta on the comedy, she went
on to appear in a number of Netflix series,
including Judd Apatow's "Love"
and the "Fear Street" trilogy.
Jacobs has also spent the years since "Community"
ended lending her voice to animated characters.
After voicing characters in "Adventure Time,"
"American Dad!", and "Long Live the Royals,"
Jacobs briefly played an unhinged superhero in
"Rick and Morty." Jacobs appeared as Supernova
in the Season 3 episode "Vindicators 3:
The Return of Worldender." In the episode,
a drunk Rick concocts a plan to terrorize a
team of prolific superheroes by putting them
through life-ending challenges and puzzles that
take a page from the "Saw" franchise. After a
number of trials and tribulations, Jacobs'
Supernova manages to make it out alive.
Despite surviving Rick's mayhem,
it remains to be seen whether
the character will ever return to
the series. Perhaps the character
could even team up with Alison Brie's
Planetina at some point in the future?
After appearing in a recurring role as Dean
Pelton in the first 2 seasons of "Community,"
Jim Rash was promoted to a series regular in
Season 3. The fan-favorite character is best
remembered for having a crush on Jeff and for
his many elaborate and sophisticated costumes.
While starring as the Dean of Greendale Community
College, Rash co-penned "The Descendants," which
nabbed him a Best Adapted Screenplay award at
the Oscars. After "Community" called it a day,
the star quickly made a guest
appearance in "Rick and Morty."
The Oscar winner appeared in the Season 2
episode "Big Trouble in Little Sanchez" as
Glaxlo Slimslom, an intergalactic marriage
counselor who tries to help Beth and Jerry
reconcile their rocky relationship. Naturally,
not even the greatest marriage experts can tackle
their marriage and chaos ensues. IGN praised the
episode and the Beth and Jerry storyline, writing:
"Between Jim Rash's guest
appearance and the wacky,
violent battle that ensued, the Beth/Jerry
storyline was unusually entertaining."
Seeing as Beth and Jerry's relationship
has evolved since the second season,
it seems unlikely that Rash will return
as the character anytime soon. The star
more recently voiced a character in
"Solar Opposites," another animated
series spearheaded by "Rick and
Morty" co-creator Justin Roiland.
"You may already be learning something important."
Throughout its six-season run,
"Community" boasted a variety
of guest and regular appearances from
high-profile and established actors. A
decent chunk of them have also popped up
in "Rick and Morty" throughout the years.
Perhaps the most obvious is Keith David,
who appeared in the final season of "Community"
as Elroy Patashnik, a failed inventor. The actor
continues to occasionally appear as
President Curtis in "Rick and Morty."
John Oliver, who most people probably know as
the host of HBO's "Last Week Tonight," appeared
in "Community" as Ian Duncan, a psychology
professor at Greendale. In 2013, Oliver also
voiced an amoeba named Dr. Xenon Bloom in the
"Rick and Morty" Season 1, episode "Anatomy Park."
Nathan Fillion, who appeared as a Greendale
custodian in "Community," also showed up
in "Rick and Morty" as a galactic secret
agent who wants access to Rick's formula
for interdimensional travel in the Season
3 episode "The Rickshank Rickdemption."
Seeing as "Rick and Morty" is still airing,
it remains to be seen if other cast members from
"Community" will appear in the animated sci-fi
series. Perhaps "Community" series
regulars Danny Pudi, Donald Glover,
Yvette Nicole Brown, and Ken Jeong will get
their shots at voice roles in the show, too.